[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos o con alfonso
armada presidente de la sección española
de reporteros sin fronteras para
conversar sobre el chaleco digital una
aplicación móvil para proteger a
periodistas en peligro a propósito del
día mundial de la libertad de prensa que
se conmemoró este 3 de mayo alfonso
gracias y en qué consiste esta
aplicación cómo podría ayudar a salvar
las vidas de los periodistas
encubrimiento
hola encantado de estar con ustedes es
un proyecto que lanzó reporteros sin
fronteras con la ayuda financiera del
ministerio español de asuntos exteriores
que no sabrán a pequeña cantidad de
dinero para desarrollarlo trabajamos con
una empresa de desarrolladores amante
mobile bueno se trata de facilitar a los
periodistas sobre el terreno una
aplicación que se descargarían de forma
gratuita en sus teléfonos móviles con
información actualizada sobre los
peligros que entraña moverse por algunos
territorios esto estaría de vinculado
además cada teléfono a unos sistemas de
alerta que podrían estar vinculados o
bien a la policía al aparato judicial a
su propio medio de comunicación a sus
familias o amigos depende de los países
en función de si la policía es fiable o
no porque hay países como sea de américa
latina que mejor no tener nada que ver
con la policía es un proyecto que
estamos desarrollando se va a presentar
en madrid el 2 de junio y esperamos que
sea una herramienta más que ayude a
proteger periodistas amenazados
precisamente por informar de situaciones
peligrosas del narcotráfico
con dos reporteros españoles asesinados
el lunes pasado en burkina faso cuando
preparaban un reportaje sobre el tráfico
y el tráfico de especies protegidas y el
furtivismo que fueron asesinados al
parecer por un grupo vinculado al
movimiento islámico al yihadismo aunque
no está confirmado del todo esta
herramienta podría quizás evitar estos
crímenes entonces alfonso estamos en que
podrían los periodistas lanzar un ss
desde una zona de peligro o que la
aplicación también les podría por
ejemplo avisar cuando estén a punto de
entrar a un lugar difícil reporteros sin
fronteras es un punto de referencia
importante para mostrar los peligros que
enfrentan los periodistas en el
cumplimiento de la labor recuerde nos
por favor las cifras tan preocupantes
que nos llevan a soluciones como esta
bueno el informe que presentamos en
edición el año pasado daba cuenta del
asesinato de 50 periodistas por hacer
precisamente información por contar la
verdad y 49 de estos periodistas
asesinados fueron periodistas locales
que trabajan en sus lugares amenazados
precisamente por informar de cuestiones
peliagudas para el poder o para los
grupos delictivos una herramienta de
este tipo esperamos que ayude
precisamente a protegerles con mapas
actualizados y niveles de alerta en
función de los peligros que pueden dañar
moverse en unas zonas waters ustedes
diría que esta aplicación es una
respuesta al retroceso en libertad de
prensa que se registró por la pandemia
ustedes mismos dijeron que la principal
vacuna contra el virus de la
desinformación es el periodismo y que
está total o parcialmente bloqueado en
73 por ciento de países
así es la pandemia servido como pretexto
para que gobiernos autoritarios o semi
autoritarios como por ejemplo el
presidente bolsonaro de brasil
restringen todavía más el acceso a
fuentes informativas potables y hayan
reprimido precisamente los intentos de
muchos reporteros de contar la verdad y
de ver la respuesta de las autoridades
en este sentido china que reprimió desde
el primer momento informaciones sobre la
pandemia pensamos es de reporteros sin
fronteras que impidió una respuesta
adecuada todo lo contrario de países
como corea del sur nueva zelanda o
taiwán que no sólo respondieron de forma
inmediata a la pandemia sino que
permitieron que la libertad de prensa a
sus ciudadanos les permitirá recibir
información actualizada y fidedigna de
lo que estaba ocurriendo
bueno y finalmente le quiero preguntar
por las mujeres si bien el peligro es
para todos las mujeres tienen un peligro
adicional a su integridad física
porque hay cómo protegernos
bueno tenemos el caso por ejemplo de la
periodista colombiana andrea aldana que
estuvo hace poco acogida en un programa
de ayuda a periodistas latinoamericanas
amenazados las mujeres por su propia
naturaleza son más vulnerables y son
extorsionadas amenazadas y en muchos
casos violadas por lo cual tienen una
mayor exposición a este tipo de amenazas
en nosotros
reclamamos una protección para todos los
periodistas expenden para las mujeres
cuando hablan de conflictos y tratan de
informar precisamente de situaciones
especialmente delicadas
alfonso muchísimas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y pues estaremos
pendientes del lanzamiento de la
aplicación en junio y sobre todo de la
utilidad de que nos represente para
ejercer la labor periodística que tenga
un feliz día ya nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]